alright it looks like we are now live
for the next AMA that is ask me anything
session I've already got a lot of
questions lined up so I'm just going to
jump into them right away I'll mention
I'm a little bit more dressy today than
usual in part because I've just finished
shooting a sequence of videos for my
upcoming existentialism class at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design on
Friedrich Nietzsche's the Spoke
Zarathustra so let me actually start a
little bit out of order with one of my
favorite youtubers math wolf ooh who is
my favorite philosopher to study that is
a very difficult one it's not asking me
as so many people always do who is your
favorite philosopher which is an even
harder one who is your favorite
philosopher to study it's a little bit
more specific I think that's changed a
lot over time I would say you know I can
give you like maybe a top five or so
Aristotle is definitely in there I love
digging through his his works because
there's so many interesting things that
I uncover
Epictetus is another one the great stoic
philosopher Cicero as well but I really
do enjoy even though I disagree with him
on so many things Friedrich Nietzsche I
think he's really an important person to
to study and who else do I find genuine
enjoyment in as well I would you know I
would actually say Saint Anselm of
Canterbury who I've done a lot of work
on over the years and who I've just got
a new piece coming out fairly soon in
the st. Anselm Journal about Saint
Anselm and virtue ethics so that's a
good segue into
Schaaf ali khan's question what is
virtue there is no agreed-upon answer
for that although some people may try to
sell you one there is a whole bunch of
different traditions of virtue
ethics very substantive traditions you
know the plate inist one which includes
people like Plutarch well then I would
say it goes into neoplatonist the
Aristotelian tradition of course the
stoic tradition I mean the Epicureans
even have their own kind of thing going
on although we don't unfortunately have
too many texts from them and then we get
into you know Christian virtue ethics
and and it goes on down to the the
present but the one thing I think you
can say that they all do have in common
is viewing virtues as states of
character that are developed through
acting and and and sort of some sort of
training or disciplining process now
what exactly are the virtues well that
kind of depends on who were we're
looking at right pair old buys that's
you know nice or someday
learn how to pronounce that correctly
since I get questions from that person
quite a bit thoughts on the ethics of
torture is the ticking time bomb
scenario useful I mean things like that
do come up from time to time don't think
so it is it is good to talk about those
say an intro or an ethics class much of
the time the the ethical decisions that
we have to make or not and quite such a
clear format especially when it when it
comes to questions of torture it's
rarely that we're considering well
there's a bomb about to go off and only
if we torture this person will we
possibly get the information that we we
need what we do know is that in many and
they knew this in ancient times by the
way torture is not a particularly
effective way of getting information let
me rephrase it's not a particularly good
way of getting true information it's a
great way of getting somebody to say
what it is that you want them to say or
what they think you want them to say so
it's not a particularly effective means
and then you know we can also talk about
all sorts of gradations is sleep
deprivation torture it certainly can be
intended to be that that way and there
is you know there
different things are going to hurt
people in different ways so that's a
good question
ap have you read Jean Baudrillard was he
a nihilist
I don't see him particularly as analysts
I guess if you know it depends on how
your understanding kneel ISM I I
understand it is an embrace of me ilysm
as sort of the solution to the problem
of evil ISM they're sort of like they
were in a situation in which as
Nietzsche diagnosed you know the highest
values have devalued themselves at least
for many people and and so that's the
nihilistic situation and then there's
like well let's embrace that and and
that could take a number of different
forms like you know just shitposting is
a great example if that's all you do I
think that's pretty me allistic
Baudrillard is a you know very prescient
analyst of media and meaning who was you
know well I mean then again so was
Kierkegaard with the president eh okay
so it's not like he's got the market
cornered on that but he's definitely
worth reading Daniel asks can I break
down blown Dells idea that our
understanding of action is fundamentally
incomplete if one brackets out the
supernatural he wasn't so concerned
about bracketing out the supernatural as
a matter of fact that's what he does
early in his work right he brackets it
he's in effect carrying out a
phenomenological analysis in order to be
able to bring people along who otherwise
in the milieu that he's writing in the
very enlightened you know third Republic
would say oh you're talking religion
that's irrationality you know the what
we call the rationalist back then or
what we now call the the secularists of
our time he was dealing with people who
were actively hostile to any notion that
there could be any connection between
religion and rationality and I mean his
view you see it discussed in the last
section of action is that you're welcome
to work out whatever sort of world view
you want to
and conception of the universe but if
you're analyzing human action there's so
many sort of places where what what
we're calling here the supernatural
something that would go beyond the
merely natural intervenes within it so
that you know you would need some sort
of you know at least you have to take
account of the fact that people can
reject that right and and that's I mean
born Dells are very difficult thinkers
one reason I haven't done that much
writing on him to adequately convey his
ideas because he's sort of like a he's
called the French or Catholic Hegel cuz
everything's connected to everything
else so that's as much as I'm gonna do
with with that for today but you know
maybe down the line I'll return to blown
del Arita but I don't write on a more
present on in too much Jack why isn't
Shasta that's labs just off the great
Russian Jewish thinker who emigrated to
Paris after the Revolution and who as
he's pointing out isn't particularly
well-known why isn't he well-known my
channel seems to be the only thing on
YouTube I could find addressing his
stuff you know I don't know if there are
any other things on YouTube I will say
this there is at least one contemporary
scholar of some significance who does
have a book chapter on chest off and
that's Boris gross in his book on anti
philosophy I think chef stuff isn't
particularly well-known for several
reasons one is that you know there's
this tendency on the part of those who
are engaging in philosophical study
particularly those who are doing
academic work to take the verdict of the
past as determinative and by the verdict
of the past I don't mean like they
actually research just off I mean they
look around they say that not a lot of
people are working out him and there's
not a lot of discussion on him so he
must not be important right and it's a
kind of intellectual laziness I would
say that that's right throughout the
Academy but also rife throughout public
for
as well so it's not like we're gonna you
know hold the the academics to a higher
standard that way and and this happens a
lot with like translation stuff going
back to blown del a lot of people
blunder was an incredibly important a
20th century philosopher a lot of people
don't know him because the only book
that got translated other than some of
his early works by fee acrid long was
the two translations of lakhs you know
first by James Somerville and then by
Oliver Blanchette all of a Blanchette by
the way translating the the you know
work again because he said the
Somerville translation was so bad and he
was teaching it at Boston College and a
lot of people will assume well if it's
not translated then it must not be
considered important enough for me to
take a look at so I'm not gonna look at
it and then of course nobody translates
any more stuff that's what's a cycle I
tried to break unsuccessfully with
translating four pieces by blown now in
my book about the 1930s efficient
rebates but unfortunately a Catholic
University Press priced ahead of most
people's price range and did not
accomplish a purpose so chef stuff
suffers from a similar sort of thing the
only reference I think that most people
encounter distressed off is in Camus
mythos if assist where he basically
writes him off as one of those crazy
existentialists and they don't they
don't go into looking well why was [ __ ]
referencing you know and what's there
the other thing is you know chef stops
works are very anti systematic and
they're I mean they're they're in some
respects more like further along the
leap faiths often Kierkegaard is more
you know corrosive cultural critique
than Dostoevsky or Nietzsche both of
whom he wrote on so it's challenging
work you know and it's not easy to to
present on you know III hard time to
being the videos that I did so let's
let's move on
ship to what extent have the editions of
Nietzsche's writings available in
English been compromised by Elizabeth
that's his sister tampering should
certain editions be avoided because of
this issue um I mean you think she
tampered a lot with us spoke zarathustra
and I don't know about that I think
biggest thing is BM they're not beyond
good and evil the will to power right
that was mostly notes and then she kind
of cobbled it together and to work she's
also you know took out apparently some
niches references to anti-semitism where
he said anti-semites are basically
idiots you know and and also some of the
criticism of you know German nation
stuff but I mean there's enough stuff in
nature that made it through her her
censorship in the early on so I don't
think any of the more recent editions
that's going to be a problem with but
you know you got a the the will the
power wasn't really a finished work she
she tried to you know turn it into
something that it wasn't so but I don't
think you really have to worry too much
about about that these days
Bruno dal Mullen asks is there a purpose
to art and that is a question that I was
bringing up with my my class at
Milwaukee Institute of Art Design this
semester you know sort of seeing what
the Art and Design students had to say
about that the ethics class that I
taught there
would it be similar to that of
philosophy or religion and expressing
the absolute as Hegel thought was the
case until his time I can tell you that
it's definitely not the case like that
for most artists today I mean quite
frankly a lot of artists are trying to
you know make a buck or make a
reputation you know express something in
that they're interested in or they see
something over here and they want to
replicate it in some way or they're
playing with ideas now he follows up can
it currently be anything we want like
donto things down toe doesn't
it can be anything we want donto thinks
that it's whatever the sort of community
of people that comprise the art world
are willing to call art right so not
everything can be passed off necessarily
as art the question is whether you can
get somebody else to accept it as art or
not I you know one of the cool things I
will say about about teaching a class on
that sort of thing is that it introduces
the students to the idea that maybe art
is located within a larger set of
purposes or values and that's not
something I think that they're getting
too much except for like well art should
serve politics or you know morality not
not you know like conservative morality
but but some other kind of morality like
you know criticism of capitalism or you
know pushing the envelope on Liberatore
movements but you know I had them read
for example Tolstoy his work on the
purposes of art and we discussed it in
class we read some con we didn't read
any Hegel maybe next time around
oh I'll work that in so all right Daniel
asks did you ever have an atheist phase
if so what was it like and what
eventually changed your mind I not only
had a phase I had a decade I was I was
you know I left the Catholic Church by
the time that I was about 16 well I was
still going to Catholic school and a lot
of it had to do with like you know
terrible catechesis you know the people
who were teaching us about religion here
in the Midwest in the 1970s and 80s most
of them didn't know anything it was all
just kind of like well you know God is
love let's be nice to each other you
know and for a kid growing up in this
area struggling with a lot of
difficulties hearing that sort of pablum
did not do anything for me and then you
know of course my dad died when I was 11
and I had the local you know Catholics
and evangelicals sort of walking me
through how not to be angry at God and
there's a big purpose to it and I was
like this is all kind of [ __ ] you
know and I saw you know the hypocrisy
and the you know sort of subordination
of genuine religious values to all sorts
of other crazy aims whether it was my my
friends going and getting themselves
confirmed so they'd get presents or
their parents you know contributing to
the to a church that they didn't believe
in all the sort of stuff and so you know
that that had an effect on me and I was
I was very interested in religions at
the time and I was you know starting to
read around and I read my way through
the whole Bible you know even the most
boring parts and you know started
learning about Hinduism and Buddhism and
Confucianism and about you know delving
into these things but I had the sort of
viewpoint that religion although it may
on occasion produce something
interesting or useful I sort of sort of
you know kind of hegelian in that way
right religion that's what you leave
behind and then you do philosophy
because religion is kind of picture
thinking for you know lower level
intellects and what changed my mind was
going to graduate school and having some
important engagements and meetings with
people who were genuinely religious and
who were genuinely intellectual and
where the two of those things were not
like in separate compartments but were
they informed each other meeting a
sister Ann Estelle great Chaucer scholar
at Purdue on a bus trip you know and
talking with her and that was that was
an interesting eye opening experience
for me seeing this kind of like you know
lady who was asking me questions about
the mário book that I was reading and
then started telling and we started
talking about stuff and it came clear
that she really had you know learned a
lot in not in spite of being religious
but precisely because of being religious
and then studying people like Thomas
Aquinas and even more so st. Anselm of
Canterbury basically to work on my Latin
but then it kind of stuck with me and
then reading you know people like
Gabrielle Marcel
blow now you know I've always been
interested in the people for whom
religion didn't solve becoming religious
or taking on religion did not solve
their problems but it actually made the
world richer and more complicated and
drew something out of them and so that I
mean the Atheist you know phase that I
guess you could call it basically went
on for about a decade for me so all
right anonymous would I be willing to do
a 24-hour live stream
I mean that's all that's a huge
commitment that would mean like I
suppose you know there'd be like
bathroom breaks or something like that
but I'm not used to like staying awake
for 24 hours at a time either and I
don't know that would that would really
wear on me how much money would you need
to get to do that could that be a
patreon goal oh it could just be a long
stream would be epic I don't know I mean
eventually I think my voice would get
worn out you know when I used to teach
at Indiana State Prison I would
sometimes have three three-hour classes
and I'd be shouting over fans and
air-conditioning units and and I would
have to like drink tea and have Ricola
drops and I would get home and my vocal
cords would just be like you know their
muscles in effect they would just be
like you know worn out you know to where
I could barely speak I don't know if I
could do that for for that long today
[Music]
but yeah it would be kind of interesting
I don't know what what's the attraction
for people to have somebody on and just
going on and on and on like that and I
don't I don't quite understand it myself
all right
Luka what are some of the best arguments
for the existence of God I don't know it
depends on what your starting points are
and what you're willing to accept I
don't think that there are you know
objectively best arguments there are
some arguments that are you know pretty
clearly weak and they recognized this
week even in ancient times like the
argument for miracles you know or the
argument from common descent Cicero goes
after those and on the nature of the
gods well you know some of the more I
guess reputable ones you know the
ontological argument not not like they
carts or like the 20th century
you know maximally perfect being
nonsense that people put out there but
like Anselm's actual argument right I
think it's pretty good but his argument
is is just you know the ontological
argument which he never called such is
just a portion of a much larger unum
argumentum so I mean there's that you
know the I kind of like Pascal's wager
but I like pasta calls actual wager not
the textbook caricature that people make
of it which means that you got to read
Paschal right so that you know that's
that's good stuff but you know different
different arguments are gonna appeal to
different kinds of people
so I know I know a lot of apologists who
like really really love Thomas Aquinas
is Fiveways I read him and I'm like man
and that's what we call God okay I guess
we go on with that then
alright Negro cornelio why do you think
Albert Camus is an existentialist
because he said he's not I've already
answered this so many times but I'll do
it again what would be the arguments it
is this confusion that he said he is not
there's a existentialist in the broad
sense there's existentialist in the
narrow sense that Chi movements right if
you want to know who he means by
existentialist you need to look at
mythos if assists look at what he
characterizes existentialism and then
you'll see that he's distinguishing
himself from that and then you look at
the broad definition of existentialism
and he fits into it I mean it's that
simple I keep on having to answer this
the same question over and over again
about that the fact that he said he's
not an existentialist in the narrow
sense doesn't mean he's not an
existentialist in the broader historical
sense any more than Gabriel Marcel
saying he's no longer an existentialist
but a Christian Socratic because start
to find existentialism the way that he
wanted to or Heidegger saying that he's
not
existentialist if existentialism means
what Sartre means we did you know when
we're doing like good history of
philosophy we look at the broad movement
and Camus who clearly fits into that you
know and why take somebody's word that
they're not part of a movement
philosophers lie about that sort of
stuff all the time all right
Leith what lethean or Leith one what are
some good sources on nominalism I don't
know maybe done you know William of
Ockham you know he's sort of like one of
the people credited with it
nominalism comes up in in the the
discussions in the earlier scholastic
period with this guy Roslyn check him
out
I don't know you probably is known as
something that I particularly work in
there's all sorts of nominalist
philosophers like like Hobbes is kind of
a nominalist you suppose you could read
him but if you want something that's
like treating nominalism as a subject
you probably have to Google you know
some sort of history of nominalism that
would that would be the way to go Adam
what is the difference between thinking
and reason for Heidegger well thinking
is broader and deeper and reason would
be you know sort of much more structured
kind of thing it's it's similar to the
distinction that gets made between
although Heidegger wouldn't like me
saying this but it's similar than a
distinction that gets made in the middle
ages between intellectus you know and
rats you know you know the the intellect
and and reason or that the German
idealist Traverse where we're
understanding our intellect is lower and
reason fear no one is above it a lot of
people have this kind of to scheme thing
you know different kinds of thoughts you
know reason is a much more structured
articulate thought that isn't able to be
is self referential it Rotolo what Falah
what philosophical works would you
recommend for business school students
as much as you can read know the you
know the people who are actually going
to go somewhere in business and are
going to survive in the long term are
usually pretty big readers and I don't
think that you need to necessarily you
know restrict yourself in that way
reading platonic dialogues would be
great work for you you know it's going
to exercise your mind reading Aristotle
I think aerosol actually has a lot to
say to business people but not directly
you have to do some of the work to kind
of you know kind of um figure out how to
apply his ideas about you know
organizations and leadership and all of
that I mean you might take a look at
people who other business people talked
about but never actually read like Adam
Smith you know I think that could be
smart right
see what Adam Smith they actually did
have to say in on the wealth of nations
rather than just you know accepting the
well the invisible hand of the market
place takes care of everything that
would be good you know also critics of
sort of the capitalism and the success
driven mentality which won't include you
know Thoreau or William James who called
success that [ __ ] goddess you know Marx
of course you know I'm not saying you
should read a lot of Marx necessarily
because that's a pretty big investment
of time but but he's you know worth
understanding I think a lot of it would
you know it would depend on on what it
is that you want to do reading Cicero
would would be pretty good for you to do
you get a good background in ancient
philosophy that way all right
ap was Whitehead of mystic I wouldn't
say he was a mystic I would say he was
pretty devoted to articulating things
and mystics are usually saying not too
much that's important can actually be
articulated but maybe you mean mystic in
a different way
I knew somebody who's gonna ask about
this five five three to seven did I see
the G Jack Peterson debate from
yesterday I did not I've read a few
summaries of it and and takes on it but
I didn't have any interest in watching
the two of them debate you know I think
I think the baits are largely PR stunts
and and kind of a waste of time
I don't I don't generally you know do
them myself
in part because they don't they don't
actually usually convince anybody and
they're so stilted and you know kind of
a strange format but yeah I mean I I
wasn't particularly interested in seeing
the two of them debate I've you know
I've read jejak stuff in the past he's
been around for a very long time you
know we were reading him back in
graduate school and you know I
occasionally read his op-ed pieces
I don't watch his his talks on videos or
anything because I'd much rather just
read what he has to say rather than try
to listen to him I don't find Peterson
profound at all as a matter of fact
people ask me about him all the time I
think that you know either either he's
being obtuse or stupid or lazy or just
opportunistic in blurring together the
categories that he does like
post-modernism and Marxism I realized
that he got that from from Stephen
Hicks's book but he should know better
than to trust something like that and
you know I I don't I don't find you know
gee Jack is kind of all over the map
he's an interesting guy Peterson I don't
find really interesting at all except as
a phenomenon so I wasn't I wasn't really
that interested in seeing what the great
debate of the century was gonna be as it
turns out the the analyses that I've
seen there's basically the Peterson
supporters who are like oh my god he did
so great and you're like come on you
know now you're really you're
straining credulity and then there's you
know the the people who are like well I
mean gee Jack didn't address some of his
points but clearly he was operating at a
much higher level than Peterson was who
didn't seem particularly prepared and
you know there's gee Jack should have
talked about this or shouldn't have
talked about this there's people who are
kind of quibbling back and forth but it
seems kind of like a the event that that
that didn't meet the hype that that was
generated about it so I'm sure I'll see
you another question about that down
below all right
the Hebrew love and support from Israel
well thanks Electra mere stoic
philosophy is in my understanding a way
to remove fears by the Faculty of reason
did they have any advice against the
fear of going mad or let's say having
Alzheimer's yeah I mean they they talked
about fear of decline I mean Seneca
actually mentions that in his letters
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on how you look at it for him
Nero decided that issue for him by
commanding him to commit suicide if he
hadn't committed suicide of course that
would have been it for his entire family
stoic philosophy is far more than just a
way to remove three fears by employing
the Faculty of reason but you know what
you want to do is is you want to look at
what's the nature of fear itself and
then you need to think about the objects
of fear and why you fear them and is it
reasonable for you to fear them and you
know there's sort of a standard way of
approaching that emotion as well as
other emotions and stoicism but yeah I
mean the decline involved in Alzheimer's
that's something that I've seen like in
my own family one of the particularly
bad parts of it is when the person
realizes they're in decline and they're
like dammit this is just going to get
worse and worse and worse and some of
them get very angry like that was the
case with my grandfather because you
know they feel like people might be
making fun of them or you know they're
they're unhappy with themselves
that's maybe something I have to face
down the line myself who knows but you
know stoic philosophy can help with it I
think so can it's like an Aristotelian
philosophy so can existentialism you
know we don't were not necessarily
confined to just one approach bruno da
mola and must read philosophers who
wrote in English okay it's a question do
we have to read philosophers who wrote
in English yeah I mean depends on why
you want to do philosophy I mean if you
want to understand human you could read
him in translation if he's been
translated into something else but why
not read him in the original if you can
you know just like if you want to read
Nietzsche it's cool if you can read them
in translation cool there yet if you
could read his German and you know I'm
not saying you need to read everybody
who wrote in English obviously people
are just churning out tons and tons and
tons of new stuff a lot of which is not
worth reading but you know I think if
you're gonna read philosophy there's
there's some English philosophers that
you really do want to read like Hobbes
and Locke and Mary Wollstonecraft and
Hume Barkley I'd say you should probably
read Adam Smith he's worth reading I
mean you know we can go on into further
centuries
Andrew Hooper what do you think is the
strongest argument against the stoic
worldview also could you explain how
Stoics could believe our desires are
under our control I don't think there's
a strong argument against the stoic
worldview first you have to define what
you think that it is and then it
probably should bear some relation with
what the Stokes actually said you know
if there's anything it's probably a
little bit too much optimism about how
similar human nature is how rational we
can be and how much can be accomplished
you can find that in Pascal right he
criticizes Stoics for that how could
Stoics believe our desires are under our
control I don't know I guess the same
way that Aristotelian is do and the same
way Plata nents do this is a commonplace
of ancient and medieval and even a lot
of early modern
theory some of our desires we can
actually influence by thinking about
things different ways it's not saying
that like you can you know snap your
fingers and say I'm no longer gonna
desire this but hell if you can't change
any of your desires what what prospects
do you possibly have right I mean this
is not this is not something radically
unique to the Stoics desires and
aversions you practice you you engage in
in habit formation you engage in
analysis you see what other people are
doing and you know I think that that
even David Hume you know with his his
famous you know he loved tag lines you
know reason can only be the slave of the
passions right well read the rest of the
treatise and see whether he really
thinks that or not he doesn't you know
we can we can change ourselves in some
some degree so James oh corn what do I
think of Richard Rorty
he was a big thing back when I was in
graduate school I read some of his stuff
I was never particularly impressed you
know the the idea that Vidkun Stein and
Dewey and Heidegger were all like anti
foundationalist
I mean did we need R or D to tell us
that you know that really didn't seem to
be like super you know news that's the
philosophy of the mirror of nature right
by the way his stuff about irony and
solidarity and that's cool to feel like
you're you know liberal intellectual
living in New England I guess I don't
know how how useful it is for the rest
of us living in the rest of the world
and it does tend to represent you know
Rory's own own views I think you know
hundred years from now he's going to be
as unknown as Herbert Spencer is to most
people in the present but you know I
think so so will a lot of other people
Shefali con which is more important in
life meaning or happiness why assume
that they're fundamentally different or
opposed to each other you know I don't
know that a
life that's happy doesn't include
meaning I think that meaning is pretty
central to actually enjoying happiness
but I don't know how you you
differentially differentiate the two I
mean first you die after actually like
clearly defined what you mean by
happiness and it's not as if
philosophers are in total agreement
about that silver shadow X any tips for
a scholarship interview is wearing a tie
overdressed nowadays no I mean if you
get some some person who's kind of a
jerk and likes to dress down which how
can you predict that maybe they'll hold
wearing a tie against you but I think
it's kind of expected if you're if
you're a guy to wear a tie it's sort of
a sign that you're taking the thing
seriously and you know I I wear ties
quite a bit at the time you know and I
also don't wear ties quite a bit at the
time sometimes I do it to convey that
what we're doing is is in a certain you
know framework right there's a
ceremonial aspect to to the tie I think
there's somebody at I don't remember who
it was it called it like you know an
important part of the bourgeois uniform
yeah we wear uniforms you know when
you're going to go play sports when I'm
going to the gym I don't wear my tie I
wear my shirt and my shorts and my gym
shoes and that's what I do there you
know and I'm going to other places I
wear my nice cozy sweater and maybe a
button-down shirt or just a t-shirt or
you know let's find it to wear in time
just make sure if you do get a tie don't
get like some goofy thing like you know
a fish tie or something with all sorts
I'm like crazy stuff on it just need to
wear something like this nice and simple
and you know you can get yourself into
the habit of it and don't worry here
I'll tell you this too so don't worry
too much about the knots right so I tie
this I'm not even sure what the name of
it is but it's it's the Matt that I
typically use because I'm a bit taller
so I have to wear long ties you know
to make it work and it's really quite
quite simple and straightforward you
want to get into the habit of being able
to tie a tie when you need to right so
you go around once like this and then
you you know pull it back through here
and you shove it through and you tighten
it up and there you go there's a nice
knot and no you know real distraction
thing you can pull it down a little bit
if you want to people get into all sorts
of crazy fancy knots I think those are
the same people who like to like you
know get really into whatever skincare
they're putting on or you know they get
very obsessed about these little details
that by the way is is what in the 1950s
and 60s getting people marginal
differentiation I think they took that
from the sociologists you'll find that
discussed in the David riemann works
like the lonely crowd right it's all
these ways that people who don't have a
way of differentiating themselves
differentiate themselves from from
others be pragmatic about ties right
good enough you know nobody's really
good if anybody's gonna judge you about
your tie
they're probably an idiot anyway so all
right
za mzingo Martin Heidegger and death
please could you advise me books about
it I don't understand German so how can
I understand philosophy on his terms you
understand English right read them in
translation Martin Heidegger talks about
being towards death in being in time so
you know you'll find it discussed in
there and there's plenty of stuff you
can read specifically just on it if
you're having trouble understanding
Heidegger there's secondary literature
out there I don't I don't see how that's
that's a big problem
Heidegger you know thinks he talks about
this in the first part of being in time
section you know that we we have this
this whether we realize it or not we
have this being towards death we can't
actually understand our own death
but but it's inevitable for us so it
sets a you know finitude for us and we
we grasp this in part although we grasp
other things as well through anxiety
this this revelatory mood or beast mo
that that he talks about I mean you
could also check out what is metaphysics
if you want to I have videos on that as
you probably know I've got a whole
sequence of core concept videos on that
short work that encompasses many of
Heidegger's great ideas but you know you
don't have to you don't have to read
everything in its original language it's
just nice if you can but read it in
translation don't be a purist just go at
it and remember too that when you first
read Heidegger you're not gonna
understand three-quarters of what you're
reading we just go at it again and again
and again until you do you know same
thing with like reading Aristotle when I
first read aerosol I was like what the
hell is this crap you know as we've read
the categories I'm like in a subject
versus about a subject what is this and
you know over time you you figure it out
philosophy is not something that you
grasp immediately the first time reading
it through it's a cumulative and sort of
Spyro --dl process you zero in on things
the Hebrew did I study Maimonides yep
back in grad school one of the people on
our reading lists didn't really get into
him much a lot of people are into
Maimonides I'm not I prefer to spend my
time on other things although I'll
probably be you know I'm doing a paper
this summer on through mos in in the
Platonic and Aristotelian traditions so
I'll have to probably dig into
Maimonides to see if he has the
interesting discussions about that or
not la hi Rodge or what are the main
things one should remember about David
Kings philosophies well here's the
number one thing the thumbnail sketches
that people make about him are usually
wrong so like there is a lot distinction
you can't get it is from a no-bullshit
sure you can you just happen to have
Ott's already in the background that's
what he was actually saying so you know
you want to actually read what Hume said
we
automatically assuming that the very
reductionist interpretations of Hume are
in fact right or like the reason and
passion thing yeah he says that but then
read his works and you'll see that
sometimes reason isn't just the slave of
the passions right so I think that's
probably the most important thing to
remember about David Humes philosophy it
is a system you know that's the other
thing to remember you've got to read the
whole thing so I would start with the
treatise on human nature and go through
that and then you know then go to the to
enquiries and then all those other
essays and stuff it'll make a lot more
sense for you
Robinson fond rung what are your
thoughts on Alexander koja kochava sort
of like to lose he's an interesting
reader of other people but whenever he
reads them you always get more cogent
and you get their person so the
introduction to the reading of Hegel
yeah it's it's pretty
you know it's connected to Hegel but
it's not straight Hegel that's its cause
yeah I'm single right and the things
that he was really interested in if you
want a more close to the text reader of
that time you want his contemporary hip
elite right who translated the the
phenomenology into French and who's got
his Genesis and structure of Hegel's
phenomenology kochava is kind of an
interesting guy also for what he got
into I mean he was one of the people who
really bought into the EU the European
Union vision and was was trying to he
played a role as a functionary within
its organization he wanted to see you
know a Europe coming together and then
the question is well how does that how
does that happen you know so cuz you
have you know interesting guide don't
always believe everything he has to say
any more than you would with like to
lose his Spinoza or Hegel or baritone
books or Nietzsche books right there's
some interesting insights there
but you're getting more or their stick
than you are you know the straight stuff
so money dolmen say what do you think
about translation and ideology and how
one affects one another well those are
two really really broad things etiology
can mean a lot of different things are
you asking like you know is it possible
to ever have a translation that's not in
some way conditioned by one's ideology
probably not but I mean it's it's
impossible to have a really great
translation in most cases anyway even
putting ideologies side just dealing
with going from one language to another
it's often quite quite tough you know
you can try to be conscious of
ideological biases you might have and
you can try to make your translation
relatively free of those but you know
it's it's you know it's pretty common
for them to interpenetrate each other I
would say translation is a great way to
learn about yourself and your capacities
to communicate something in another
language that's kind of an interesting
idea
so yeah let's see by Riggin 13 what do
you think of the theology of Pelagius he
was seriously overshadowed by Augustine
I don't know I've never read like
Pelagius straight I don't know if we
even have him straight but so I can't
say that much about it he you know he
wasn't just overshadowed by Augustine he
there were a lot of people who are
ejected Pelagianism here in the West we
we tend to frame it just in terms of
those two by themselves but you know
people were worried about his doctrines
in other places I will say that you know
pelagianism shows you know is it
represents kind of a a recurring
tendency this this notion that well we
can we can sort things out on our own
that it's a little bit perhaps over
optimistic
about our capacities wouldn't you say
alright let's see what else did we got
here
Adam are am i familiar with Alexander do
get in his fourth political theory I
haven't really read any any Dugan so I
don't know what it is fourth or second
or third or first political theory is
maybe some day if I have the time I will
or somebody sends me a book I'll check
it out but I don't have much much time
for that sort of thing
Robinson fun broom what are your thought
already did that coach Jeff Allen Moises
Duncan what's the best order to read
Aristotle there isn't one you start
reading and keep going at it and then
going back and rereading there there is
no easy formula I'm actually going to
talk it you know you know of course that
I started a new series of self-directed
how to do self-directed study on
different authors and then I'm going to
be doing one on Aristotle next month so
you know you can tune into that I
usually you know I have my students
reading stuff from the Nick o McCann
ethics because I think that's the most
accessible a lot of people like to start
students with throwing them into the
categories it's a great way to turn
people off on Aristotle but you know if
you're more into the logic stuff than
the ethics stuff why not do that or why
not start with the rhetoric or why not
start with the politics or if you know
you want to get nice and confused start
with the metaphysics and the on the soul
right there's no good way to get into
aristotle there's no best like do this
do this and do this
adam how much mysticism is there in
Hegel's philosophy
I'd say none you know again mysticism
depends on what you mean by it right I
mean if you mean like what Bertrand
Russell or other analytics mean by it
then where things just aren't clear and
there's there's like some kind of fuzzy
feeling about something I suppose
there's probably some mysticism there
but that's an abuse of the term that
they got into but you know actual
genuine mysticism and a lot of people
are like to
kaboom and all that there might be some
you know inspiration for Hegel from that
but I wouldn't say that Hegel himself is
actually in any real respect a mystic
he's sort of an anti mystic he he
doesn't want those kind of appeals to
intuition and you know the what lies
beyond thought he wants to bring
everything within thought and make it
conceptual but faithfully so he's kind
of the opposite of a mystic which is you
know part of what attracts me to him
because I don't like mystics
I'm not into people who are like oh you
got it all right you can see Sasi in the
background prowling around or
sixteen-year-old cat I'm not I'm not
into people who make appeals to like oh
you if you kind of look you know you got
a deep in your your your understanding
of this and open yourself up to the
universe or any of that sort of nonsense
you know I want to know what are you
actually bringing to the table if you
want to tell me that there's some sort
of process that I have to undergo before
I'm going to understand I'm cool with
that because that's part of virtue
ethics but I'd better I'd better find
some understanding and it better be
something that can be articulated at the
end of the process all right mm not what
do you think about Ortega
that's Ortega y Gasset rat rat Co
vitalism maybe you could do a core
concept video about it well I probably
wouldn't do a core concept video about
Ortega if I ever do get around to
shooting stuff I'd have to do a series
right because what's the point in just
doing one single video we're taking a
Gasset as somebody who I read a long
time ago haven't read that much lately
the one spanish author who i have been
reading more frequently lately is Miguel
de Unamuno
I'd wanted when I was doing the
existentialism series which I may revive
again some day you know the longer
one-hour lecture videos to do some work
on Ortega y Gasset but I never got
around to it and so we'll see what
happens I don't I don't have enough to
say about about him Robinson from Broome
the Hegelian arguments stoicism is
simply a form of slavery ality no that's
wrong
the Hegelian position and stoicism is
that it comes out of slave morality but
it's not a form of slave morality it's
something quite different and that's why
it's got its own section in stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy consciousness
so you're mixing it up with perhaps
Nietzsche
but even Nietzsche doesn't think that
it's just a form of slave morality
thinks that that it represents something
that is productive but wrong so you
don't want to over generalize like that
Valentino Ralph John what do you think
about using philosophy as a meaner and
aid in order to broaden one scientific
insightfulness for example if you're in
two languages and linguistics you study
plato's Cratylus etc I guess it's fine
for that I mean why wouldn't you if
you're into languages and linguistic
study everybody who's had something
interesting to say about languages and
linguistics
unless you're kind of like you know many
linguists and they don't know about
their own discipline and it's its past
and similarly sociologists who haven't
read Marx or Weber or Durkheim or
Auguste Comte for that matter or Herbert
Spencer don't really know that much
about their their discipline so it's
good for that and it's good for I guess
learning some more things what they have
to offer different different theoretical
disciplines probably varies considerably
from discipline to discipline though I
don't know that like you know for
somebody who's doing chemistry that
reading ancient philosophy is going to
or modern philosophy and it's going to
be that particularly helpful but you
know for the social sciences
sure original bon jovi do you consider
stoicism a form of de ontology or virtue
ethics my own reading of Cicero Seneca
and epic Tina's tensors virtue ethics
but my textbook labels it is a form of
proto communism why do you have to
choose between the two you know is a
theory only de ontology or virtue ethics
that's the sort of you know schematic
textbook approach that people take but
that's wrong real virtue ethics taken to
account I mean read Alistair McIntyre
you know who is somebody by the way who
sees stoicism as proto konchem ISM but
he at least recognizes that virtue
ethics has to engage with other
traditions in order to strengthen itself
stoicism has you know virtue it is a
virtue ethics but it's also a virtue
ethics with a lot of deontological
elements to it you know as is to some
degree even Aristotle right Aristotle in
nickim McCann ethics book 1 lays down
some day anta logical guidelines saying
not everything has a mean can't commit
adultery to the right extent that's
always wrong
that's very dant illogical right try to
avoid reductive views you know you're
probably not going to get a great read
on stoicism from a textbook anyway but
you know it's you you want to yeah I
mean reading Cicero Seneca Epictetus
tend towards virtue ethics there's also
a lot of data logical aspects to that
right so what you can say is they're not
hedonists that's pretty clear by the way
the paper that I mentioned earlier
that's coming out on st. Ansem who by
the way has a lot in common with the
Stoics on this this sort of thing also
construes and some as a virtue ethicist
whose theory has a lot of des
ontological aspects to it so that's kind
of worth checking out Diego Gerardo tink
Oh ahran don't Oh what is your take on
abortion I think abortion is a bad thing
and we should have much less of it if
possible I also you know tend to think
that most of the anti-abortion activists
are people motivated more by fear and
envy and hate than any sort of real care
about the child if you're going to
insist that adoption you know carrying
the child to birth and adoption should
be the the alternative to abortion then
you better put your money where your
mouth is and not just adopt children of
your own but work towards a world in
which children who are in fact going to
be adopted or
children who are gonna be kept by
low-income mothers who are gonna have a
hard time are not going to be you know
having a very rough ride of it so you
know I I actually see both sides is like
full of hypocrites and fools and and
people who claim to be of goodwill but I
actually aren't on the abortion issue
and that's been going on for quite a
long time pretty much all of my life I'd
say Gabriel Connor is someone who enjoys
saying handsome and other Christian
philosophers how does one counter
dispute Kant's arguments concerning the
inability to have knowledge of God his
arguments seem very strong well they
seem very strong from a conscient
perspective don't they you can say it
Kant's wrong about this this sort of
stuff I mean why why assume that that
just because you're in the conscience
system and you've bought into his you
know basic assumptions and terminology
that he's actually got those things
right I mean look at his successors
Hegel you know right after him yep
ontological argument holds and here's my
own version of it you know so you know
how do you counter a dispute Kant's
arguments you relativize them they you
know they're great within Khan's own
system I don't know that they actually
apply that well out of it unless you buy
into that you know Jonah Oliver best
book for a general overview of
philosophy no idea I mean it depends on
who you know what kind of reader you are
and I can tell you that when it comes to
the history of philosophy when I was you
know student we use tree tree
cobblestones history of philosophy I
like it because cobblestone is usually
not wrong about stuff and gives you a
nice you know selection of passages and
he's pretty comprehensive but you know
if you like more popular stuff you know
there's other ways to get into it as
well I don't think there is a best book
you know I Ross the knees how do you get
a religious person to understand the
flaws of objective morality I don't know
I mean I don't know that many religious
people who talk about objective morality
so I think we're moving in different
circles I don't know
why we would not want to have objective
morality it sounds like a good thing to
me that that it doesn't take into
account subjective motives or
circumstances or things like that I'm
not sure why we want to reject it mr.
big week me do you think Sartre
misinterprets Heidegger like many
suggest if so do you feel like it's to
the detriment of sart's thought well
Heidegger certainly seemed to think
Sartre was misinterpreting or
selectively interpreting Heidegger's
thought he's definitely you know got a
different view on nothingness he's much
more Cartesian in his orientation and
then Heidegger is I think Sartre is
doing his ultimately is doing his own
new thing which is you know so his
reappropriation of Heidegger I'm not
going to say it's exactly like say Marx
appropriation of Hegel but you're
getting something very different as a
result right and you know the the
question you have to ask is is what
start doing you know worth checking out
and thinking the world through and I
think the answer is yes I like Sartre
quite a bit I don't agree with him on
quite a few things but I also don't
agree with hiding aren't quite a few
things and I think he's worth checking
out as well you know I guess you know
the question could be whence art is
reinterpreting Heidegger in ways that go
against Heidegger is he misinterpreting
Heidegger in the sense that like he just
doesn't understand Heidegger or does he
know what he's doing and he's you know
steering it deliberately in that
direction I would say he's doing the
latter I would say also like when he
misrepresents Gabriel Marcel or cholera
ecology Oscars he he's just doing so
deliberately to I don't think that he's
just not getting it I think that that
he's choosing that that stands because
he wants to work out his own thing and
I'll mention to that you know when it
comes to like ethics
Sartre never managed to produce a viable
existentialist ethics it fell to Simone
de Beauvoir to do that in the ethics of
ambiguity which is you know you if
you're gonna read Sartre you should read
her to I think all right one two three
leo one two three what are my thoughts
on veganism I've got quite a few I think
that in general it's good if we start
moving away from a heavy meat and dairy
dependent regime that's dependent upon
factory farming which is you know really
a horrible way of mistreating animals
and creating misery and passing it on to
you know savings for the consumer we've
got ourselves caught within a food
system that's that's quite horrific when
you look into it that said you know I'm
not a vegan and I'm not a vegetarian
either I'm an omnivore and you know in
part that's because I'm sort of still
thinking this stuff through and and
determining what I want to do I have a
lot of sympathy for low-income people
for whom we've created situations in
which they're effectively priced out of
ethical meat or dairy and have a rough
time even acquiring you know vegetables
that aren't dependent on human misery in
one way or another and we have lots and
lots of misinformation out there I think
that you know vegans come in a couple a
couple different brands right there's
the purists who are like they're
basically like a religious sect and like
many sects excommunication excommunicate
each other as heretics quite a lot and
you know I don't fully understand what
the well I mean we could delve into the
impetus for that in all sorts of ways I
think it's kind of cool that that you
know things like the beyond meat burger
is now going into fast food although I
don't think fast food is necessarily the
best thing but you know it's
it's there's a lot to be said there I
will say this I think that it's it's
very important not to be a super purist
about this sort of stuff and be more
like listen we can at least move in this
direction and that's not nothing you get
you get this this idea from a lot of
people not just in terms of veganism but
any sort of intentional ethical living
that like if you're not doing everything
everything you're doing is crap and
nothing and I think that that's a bad
way to go about looking at things all
right here is a question from our brain
hurts a lot
is there any philosophers that discuss
the threats of climate change and how to
look at this problem in a philosophical
way yeah there are this is not like an
area of my particular emphasis but
there's a lot of people working in
environmental ethics who who talk about
this and who have been talking about it
for years I would say that you know
broadly the utilitarian tradition so
think about people like today Peter
Singer think think that that it's
important to address it not just for its
effects on us but also the effects on
animals who also suffer I would say that
here's the thing to say you can take a
lot of different philosophical
traditions and adapt them to this
question I've been thinking about it in
terms of like stoicism and Aristotelian
ism and what what these thinkers who
generally assume that we couldn't
destroy the environment what they would
make of it if they realized just how big
of an impact we human beings could have
and what sort of rethinking x' would
have to happen so for example Stoics
they buy into the ancient notion of you
know man is the rational animal we are
sort of a fundamental leap in value
above the other animals who are
irrational and the other animals and
plant life and the world itself is here
for us for rational life and not not
vice-versa I think that there are people
out there you know great example of
somebody who's doing a lot of thinking
about this today and the stoic
communities kind of lighting you know
but I think Christopher Gill is also
doing a good bit of thinking about this
and so are others and there's people
from a neo Aristotelian perspective who
are doing that I think if you're if
you're looking at people coming at it
more from a like Rawls Ian or
development perspective you can talk
about the impact on the poor especially
I mean think about so things are things
are you know in sort of flux for us here
in the developed West take for example
the state that I'm in I'm waving in the
background because you know Wisconsin is
behind it all around me things have
changed radically here the weather
patterns are different we don't get snow
that sticks you know species are now
invading that that are replacing our
native species you say well that's
always happening yeah but I mean the
evidence is pretty clear that not only
are the cyclical things going on but
also there's man there's a human human
generated climate change as well and
that's that that could be good or could
be bad people are like well I don't have
to shovel snow as much you know but you
know we're also getting other other
things happening as well and if you
think about where the majority of human
beings live those areas are going to be
majorly majorly impacted by climate
change and it's only a question now of
what we do in response to it how we plan
for it and and whether we can curb the
trend or whether we don't have the
political will to push that through you
notice that here in America we have one
party that believes as a matter of dogma
that there is no such thing as human
human produced climate change the
Republican Party and we have a Democrat
Party that although they talk about you
know a green new deal and stuff like
that really when push comes to shove
they don't do a hell of a lot to change
change things right not enough to make a
significant difference
unfortunately in other places where
conservatives were a lot more rational
about it they're starting to buy the
American conservative line and say that
it doesn't exist either so you know we
could we can approach this issue of
climate change
there's people who are working directly
on it and I don't know that much about
it and then there's all sorts of ways
that we can take the philosophies that
we have out there and speak about it in
meaningful ways so yeah that's that's
I'd look into like environmental ethics
again not an area of my particular
concentration all right white Breyer
says chest off is well-known and
post-soviet Russia I'll have to take
your word for it because I don't know
about it made of clay - I think
philosophical phases ever end
as in we never stopped being into a
philosopher even if we say we're not
well you know because I had a VidCon
Stinney Enphase doesn't mean I don't
read and teach and you know talk about
Vidkun Stein right or a Sartre phase I
just talked about start earlier but we
do leave the phases sometimes behind and
some people stay in their entire life
they become Nietzschean and stay in
Nietzsche forever that's that's their
thing Oh original bon jovi how do you
suggest dealing with professors
pragmatists in particular who disparage
the ancient and medieval thinkers as
nothing more than historical curiosities
and this goes equally for analytic
philosophers most of whom know nothing
about the past and this also goes for
many continental thinkers who are like
well they're all conservatives right and
and maybe read some of them don't read
them so that they can critique them
you're not going to make much headway
with them I ended up having to do my
ancient and medieval philosophy when I
was in graduate school pretty much
outside of the department with classics
English and who else speech
communication to a certain extent
studying Aristotle you're probably not
going to I mean here's I deal with them
just like not and then go on and do your
work and find yourself people and
communities and organizations that
actually do take medieval and ancient
philosophy seriously and you know
support yourself with those so you know
we've got this whole modern stone
movement granted there's a lot of people
in it who don't really know that much
about stoicism but the people who are
like you know the big heavy hitters they
sure do you know the people everybody on
our modern stoicism team are people that
I'm proud to be working with right
there's a great conference here in
Wisconsin
every year at Marquette University just
down the road called the Aristotle and
the Aristotelian tradition conference
actually it's back that way Marquette's
down down the road that way I'll be
presenting there this year in June so
you know you you want to find these
forums where there are people who really
do take this stuff seriously and that'll
be your your your sort of lifeline when
you're dealing with all the the nonsense
from the people who are dismissing
ancient and medieval thinkers in your
University and you know the stuff that
those people do have to contribute you
know the pragmatist they're worth
studying you know learn from them it
doesn't mean you have to be like I'm
only doing ancient and medieval so I
shouldn't study William James why I'm
James is a lot of fun but a lot of
interesting stuff happening in his work
I teach him pretty routinely in my
classes I'm not a pragmatist but you
know he's worth worth looking at second
thing about you know Charles purse or
Royce or I mean Dewey I got kind of a
bad taste for him because I was at si
you know like you know do me and Bob
there but you know there was even some
stuff that's worth checking on doing all
right
Waldemar so when that extensive video on
the neoplatonist coming out next year
it'd be fine by me I don't really do
videos on movements so I'm not sure
where you got that idea from maybe down
the line I will but right now I'm doing
a lot of core concept videos and trying
to get back into doing book review
videos and other things like that so I
mean I'll work on some neoplatonist
figures but I don't know the next time
I'll get them I got all this
existentialist stuff I got a shoot
and then I gotta start thinking about
what I need videos for in the fall as
well
Tobias does the training of the
Guardians
just lost his thing let me see here
there's a question about the Guardians
boy there's a lot of questions piling up
here to do where is it ah
the training of the Guardians and
Plato's Republic promote collectivism or
is it rather promoting education why not
both you know that it depends on what
you mean by collectivism collectivism
just for the sake of like whatever
though the society says is good no but
it is promoting a kind of organic notion
of society where the Guardians excuse me
where the Guardians serve some
determinate purposes and their lives are
oriented around them so that that I
think is is is quite important let me
see here there's another question Bob
Johnson how do I prepare myself for
writing philosophy I don't actually
prepare myself because I've been doing
it for so long that it's just something
that I I do is sort of like asking
somebody who you know sings all the time
what are the warm-up exercises that you
do well maybe I don't do any warm-up
exercises anymore
now maybe other people would have good
exercises for warm-up but I don't know
let's see here
I've read sixty pages of Athens and
Jerusalem by chef stuff it's hardly as
valuable as a couple paragraphs of
phenomenology of spirit of being in time
I disagree but you know you get out of
it what you get out of it you know he
grew Cornelia what do I think of Thomas
and angles vision of the absurd having
read Nadel for four years so I don't
know
I'm sure Nagel had some interesting
thoughts on it
well bean meant what are my thoughts on
perennial philosophy if we're talking
more like the Huxley kind of thing I
don't really buy into it as a matter of
fact there's there's also a Catholic
version where they do have a philosophy
perennis I'd never find that sort of
framework very interesting I actually
rather to say there's a great diversity
within the field of philosophy not
everything fits into a nice you know
schema like like that not everybody's
doing the same thing
Ian what is a good way to get into
general philosophy for someone totally
unfamiliar with it I don't know what
general philosophy is I'm a thinker
texts person I say start with primary
texts and get into it but that that's my
take you know a lot of people don't do
it that way you can always buy yourself
a textbook and I mean I I encountered
philosophy that way when I was younger
you know I'd buy a buy a thing at a used
bookstore and you know page my way
through it and then they'd have like
their own version of how things are all
set out it's not gonna kill you you know
but eventually you want to read some
some primary stuff all right
shaf Ali Khan would it good a mean by
the soul who sees Beauty usually walks
alone Gerdes somebody I haven't read for
a long time I was cutting into him back
in graduate school for a little while I
don't know probably that when we when
we're appreciating beauty not everybody
is in on the experience and it's
difficult to communicate it to others ma
Needleman say what do you think about
the Oscar Wilde an art art for art's
sake it's interesting that you don't see
that formula in Wilde's
works it was kind of circulating around
and we associated with Oscar Wilde but
as I was teaching this ethics for
artists and designers and and going
through my text and deciding what to
give them
I had a hell of a time finding some you
know the formulations that are close to
that in Oscar Wilde and so I you know I
think that there's there's a something
to be to be said for it
most of my students interestingly these
artists and designers I asked them what
do you think about this idea of art for
art's sake and they are like I don't
really buy it it seems kind of
self-indulgent you know dissociated from
everything else
they couldn't say well what else was art
supposed to be for in any sort of
consensus but they were kind of
uncomfortable with it
let's see Pro Adam what are some common
misunderstandings people make about
Hegel well there's lots of them I guess
the biggest one would be thinking that
you can make sense of it with a quick
read or you know I'm getting people
jumping in and my half-hour Hegel videos
and they're like I don't understand
what's going on here you know and it's
clear that they didn't begin at the
beginning
you can't like skip stuff in Hegel
here's another one the master-slave
dialectic is is not the main the main
show and Hegel's thought there's a it's
only just a tiny little sliver of what's
going on the thesis antithesis synthesis
schema that's not actually Hegel it's
way more complicated than that so I'd
say those are some of the basic ones
Andrew are the Penguin Classics the way
to go for Seneca and epictetus or could
you recommend other additions I don't
know I mean I read this stuff in in
multiple editions and often times in the
original so you know there's Crescenta
there's a nice set that's come out
recently with some pretty new
translations but I don't remember
they're you know they're sort of big
thick books they might be from Cambridge
or Oxford or
somebody like that Margaret graver is
one of the people who was involved in
that let me see if I could actually find
that they were they were quite nice oh
yeah here we go
so like the letters on ethics graver and
long translated them and that is
University of Chicago Press okay so very
cool those are those are pretty good but
you know I'm not a good person to ask
because I will jump from Edition to
Edition to Edition when I'm when I'm
like doing my work Epictetus I've got my
Loeb Edition which has the English and
Greek on facing pages and that's that's
what I'm using made of clay when I ever
try twitch streaming I don't know I I
don't know what twitch streaming is so
it's hard to say whether I'd try it
Hamid sure Shariati in what ways of the
philosophies and Spinoza Nietzsche
comparable not much I mean Spinoza is a
hardcore monist Nietzsche is a pluralist
of pluralists I mean there's very little
in which they actually connect up with
each other I'd say
Tomica is what is what is the best
source to study stoic notions of
personal identity to death play any
important role on the stoic account
death kills you I mean just read the
classic stoic text read Seneca Epictetus
Marcus Aurelius said you know Epictetus
says you are your pro races that's the
core of who you are
but all three of them have some some
view on that a night at Pont can I
please upload some videos on Eastern
philosophy I get asked this every time
I'm not an expert on Eastern philosophy
I don't read poly or Sanskrit or
Mandarin let alone classic Chinese I
also have a lot of other things I have
to do
so I'm probably not going to be
producing anything on Eastern philosophy
anytime soon I mean if somebody wants to
Commission me to do it then I guess I
could do oh here's an interesting one
original Bon Jovi what do I make of
William James reformulations of Pascal's
wager so that would be in the will to
believe which I will be teaching here in
Milwaukee at my MATC intro to philosophy
class when about two weeks from from now
two weeks in two days next week we're
doing existentialist thinkers that are
jumping into James I think that I think
the will to believe is a great essay and
and you know one of the problems with
Pascal's wager is it's very centered on
like the Christian way of looking at
things
James kind of generalizes it I think
he's totally right that there are some
things we have to commit ourselves to
first and then we get to figure out
whether they're actually true or useful
or generative or not Janus G Joe is
untruth the condition of life how do I
live with it I guess if if you if you
think it is then maybe you want to start
with Nietzsche's on truth and lies at an
extra moral sense which I have a whole
sequence of core concept videos on so
you could you could you could check that
out Andrew what did the Stoics mean by
nature very complex thing includes the
natural world that includes our nature
there's a whole video that I did on what
in accordance with nature means for the
Stoics so you might want to check that
out it's something I'm working on a book
on still it's not a simple thing I've
also got a few essays and stoicism today
about that monny demas what I think
about Russian formalism especially
Bakhtin well I'm a fan of octene I don't
get to read them very much but I really
enjoy his problems of Dostoevsky x'
poetics and you know I think that's
that's you know a great approach to two
things
his book on Rob Lai I used to really
like no not quite so much I've never
made my way through art and
answerability but I'd like to down line
so I enjoy him here's a very different
kind of question how do I find my
passion in life now if you're asking
like in the generic I'd say well you got
to kind of like look around and open
yourself up to things and see what you
respond to and also be ready to have it
grow or change on you over time for me I
didn't have to find it instead it found
me I'm kind of fortunate in that respect
when it comes to philosophy right so you
know I think I think we're in a very
fortunate time in that we have access to
the Internet and that opens us up to so
much more than we had available to us in
the past we can save ourselves a lot of
time right but then a lot of the
Internet is pretty shallow although very
wide you got to figure out how do you
get deep into things all right I am
going to we have 7 minutes left I'm
gonna scroll down and see what else is
easy to take and just answer things in
rapid succession here's a here's a quick
one ever considered growing the full
beer this is from Jordan Deuter no
because it doesn't grow here
it's very straggly here so that's that's
why I have the beard that I do according
to you the Socrates Socrates conviction
was right or wrong Manish Pardeshi
it was wrong but you know it worked out
right for history let's see what else we
got here good to do scrolling back up
thoughts on Rene grinning I think you
know I've said this many times
there's traditionalists out there that
you can read he's not somebody that I've
spent any real time with I read that
more you know 19th century
traditionalists seems to be doing more
or less the same kind of thing only he's
mixing in perennial philosophy and stuff
from other religions in with it
wrath of the Lamb are you considering
doing a banjo video again would be nice
if you showed us some of your best songs
I'd have to start practicing so that
means that if I do it it'll be sometime
in the summer because I hardly ever have
the time nowadays to to practice but I
could do some that would be kind of fun
I did a banjo video for my son who was
asking for it for his class and then I
made it available for my patreon
supporters to check out all right to do
where do I stand on the realism
anti-realism debate from - 2046 I don't
you know I
most of these sort of isms I don't
really worry too much about again I'm a
thinker and text person right so yeah
jack of kosto were you always smart or
did you work your way through philosophy
through hard work and perseverance so
you know I'm one of those people who's
smart in some respects and dumb in other
respects I've made a lot of dumb
mistakes in my life some of which
stemmed from you know just coming from a
background where people didn't didn't
have that that much useful to provide me
with you know I was in effect
first-generation college but you know
some of it also stemmed from my own
obstinacy and inability to see what was
staring me in the face at the time
philosophy has helped me with that I
don't I don't usually think of myself in
terms of being smart or not I did a lot
of very hard work when I was in graduate
school both
like my languages and with studying the
history of philosophy and I've been you
know relying on the fruits of that for
for quite some time especially as I
taught a lot of classes and I I learned
a lot too by teaching classes and
developing resources every time like I
you know shoot a video I'm relearning
something although it's it's a constant
process as Plato points out the
symposium where our minds there's always
bits going out and new bits coming in
we're not they're not permanent
possessions that we have we have to we
have to keep up with it so it's sort of
like working out but here's what I will
say anybody who wants to study
philosophy can study philosophy and if
you stick with it you will make progress
in studying it so this is this is quite
important you know have some confidence
in the material have some confidence in
yourself as they said in the Plato video
that I released here's a funny question
horizon Berg dr. Sandler who are you and
why was this in my recommended feet I
don't have any clue why it was in your
recommended feed you can find out all
about me you know just Google right I'm
a person who does philosophy in a public
way and doing that for years but it's
easier just to like use use Google Adam
spera did you see the Dziedzic debate no
I deliberately didn't want to see that
because I thought it was it would be
kind of a waste of my time and I have so
many other things I needed to do instead
let's see here
binary epidemic what do I think of the
rise in pagan sentiments in Europe I
think paganism you know never went away
you know if you read stuff in life from
the Middle Ages it's not as if like the
church came in and then suddenly this
this vast agreement descended upon
everybody they're constantly constantly
having to struggle with not even just
paganism but just like you know things
falling apart and some the guy who do a
lot of work on he's got to write these
letters like saying don't let this
priest out into the town because every
time he does he gets drunk and starts
chasing women you know
we got a knock that stuff right and so
there's always been sort of a struggle
Europe was never fully Christianized and
even then when it you know the parts of
it that were they didn't do it right you
know that's like somebody like
Kierkegaard points out so I think it
makes good sense as religion in its
traditional senses decline people want
to find alternatives to that and one
alternative is like a return to what
they think to be paganism which is
usually pretty far removed from any any
you know real historical paganism but
you know people like to do that sort of
thing let's see do see another one
Joanne Lafont have I heard about gene
Wolfe's death I certainly did sad to
hear about it he's just one he was one
state south of here and I was hoping you
know I did a talk on him in our series
and I was kind of hoping that maybe I
would actually like find the time to
write him a letter and see if I could
meet him and chat that would be kind of
cool but he's gone and that means the
loss of a great speculative fiction
writer personally wall of a lot of
philosophy into his work so it's it's
kind of sad but you know he lived a long
and productive life let's see what else
can I go out on let me see if there's a
nice easy one to take this this is kind
of a joking one it's too good it's way
too good says this philosophy stuff is
great and all but you should just start
selling out theaters and hosting WWE
debate wrestling matches against
conservatives instead well I'm not in a
shape to do wrestling matches although I
do make it to the gym every once in a
while I am
not remotely in the shape that I used to
be back in my teens and 20s and you know
I I do enjoy the philosophy stuff I
can't really picture myself deliberately
shifting into a career that would mean
not doing it anymore so you know maybe I
could sideline that's that but I think
I'd want to be the guy who's like the
announcer instead you know and now so
and so has got him in a saree tazed hole
or something along those lines all right
let's see if there's one other nice
thing I can I can go out on although
that was it was quite a funny one to do
there we go okay so here's a good one to
give kind of a pep talk on so Yakko
pasto I'm finding philosophy too
difficult even after spending a decent
amount of time with it
I love the subject but I still don't
understand most of it and he follows up
saying I'm interested in Heidegger and
nature for now so you picked three very
difficult thinkers and you know yeah you
still don't understand most of it well
that's going to be the case for a while
not least because each of the thinkers
that you're picking not only to writes
in a difficult way and each of them is a
great stylist too by the way but they're
also referencing all these other
thinkers I would say you probably would
be better off backtracking a bit and
starting with you know ancient and then
medieval philosophy and going into
modern philosophy and setting yourself
you know set of like goals you know like
maybe pick 20 people along the way to
Nietzsche Heidegger and Foucault who you
want to understand halfway-decent a
Plato would be one of them Aristotle
would be one of them you know pick
epictetus or Seneca for a stoic and you
know decart would be one and and you
know that will be quite helpful for you
the other thing to keep in mind is it's
okay if you if you only understand a
quarter of what you're reading when
you're when you're beginning that's
actually pretty good so just keep
at it and more and more that will be
slowly become clear over time I still
you know I mean I've been doing
philosophy now I mean I first started
academic philosophy in college in 1990
so almost 30 years of that I mean it
studied a little bit before but I still
find things around like holy crap I've
been getting this wrong the entire time
or I didn't read I didn't know about
this you know and I still read people
who are new to me as well so it's okay
if you're not getting it all at once and
so I think that's that's a nice positive
thing to go out on thanks to everybody
for your questions and comments
obviously I didn't get to all of them
but you know I'll do another one next
next month I'll also be doing some
philosophy pop ups one here on YouTube
one on Facebook live and I'll announce
those in my Facebook and YouTube and to
my patreon supporters as well so have a
great rest of the day I've got to get
back to work I've got a ton of work
waiting for me for the rest of the day
and yeah just you know all those of you
who are studying philosophy just keep
plowing away at it as they say these
days the slang is keep grinding and it
will be rewarding for you